[Music]
John James is a Republican in Michigan
he's challenging Democratic senator
debbie Stabenow in the state he's 37
years old he flew helicopters during the
Iraq war he's been an underdog for the
entire race but polls now show him
within striking distance of the
incumbent senator you think all of that
might make a compelling news story but
the press have largely ignored James
while turning bet toe or orc into a
national celebrity he's our Bobby
Kennedy why is that that's the question
we don't often have candidates on what
we're doing so tonight John James joins
us which James thanks a lot for coming
on so the reason that we wanted to talk
to you is this is one of the few
questions that we think we can answer I
want to play for our viewers a recording
that you made this is a reporter who
called you you didn't answer hung up or
thought she hung up but didn't and
here's what she said and you captured on
tape my number is nine eight nine
extension 109 thank you yeah if he beats
her Jesus that would suck
I don't think it's gonna happen its ass
he's hard to get ahold of I hope he
doesn't win for that reason too so suck
you have anything resembling a page one
uh article you hear me give anything I
mean uh top story did ya
so that's Brenda battle she's reporter
from a local newspaper and guess she
doesn't like you is that your read on
that I would say so I would say so I
think this is just kind of the the
indication that you're getting the
uphill battle that many of us are facing
because a lot of the bias that we're
seeing out there is just not fair for
those who share different opinions than
than some in the progressive liberal
media yeah I mean that it's kind of on
display there what do you think your
shot is tomorrow
well we've closed the gap by the grace
of God in our grassroots army the
excitement here is amazing we're
actually in the next room we have a
rally going on with a couple couple
hundred people back there who are fired
up about getting out the vote here in
Michigan but I'll tell you we have the
energy because people are sick and tired
of being condescended to and the
ineffectiveness and hyper partisanship
of debbie stabenow people want a combat
veteran who understand what it takes to
take care of our veterans and keep this
country safe people want a business
leader who understands how to create
jobs in the real world somebody who
understands how to grow our economy in
the state of Michigan and the liberal
bias that you're seeing against this
race that you just heard you just heard
for yourself right here in the state of
Michigan are intent on maintaining the
status quo because I don't fit in
anybody's little black box a little
white box I don't fit in their little
red box with a little blue box I'm red
white and blue baby and I'll tell you
what when I get to Washington I'm gonna
make sure that we make sure we move this
state forward and we move this country
forward and we're not going to let
anybody stop us it's about keeping
America safe and it's about putting
Michigan number one
so I was wondering why you know why have
we been here we've been hearing so much
about bateau or orc or whatever his fake
name is and nothing about you and that
we know why so if you come to Washington
and we hope you do hope you'll make a
stop on this show so we can hear more
miss James thank you very much ah thanks
a lot go to John Joseph center comm god
bless